wow wow people
you know actually
i love people because
my works about people
it's actually about bringing people
together
i'm an artist i mean until i found a
real job but now it looks like it's
getting pretty serious
but you know i also love walls and i
know that walls are supposed to divide
us
but i think i found a way
to use walls to bring us together
and i've tried this in different place
this was in israel palestine 15 years
ago
where with my friend marco i took photos
of israeli and palestine doing the same
job and then pace them on israeli city
and palestinian city and people couldn't
even recognize who is who
this was in the favelas of brazil
faces a woman on the heels of the
community
often the first target of the violence
that is happening there this is a local
museum we have in paris it's called
duluth i don't know if you've heard
about it but i thought i'd give it a
shout out
and with 400 people and paper and glue
we we paced the entire plaza to make the
pyramid ten times bigger
this was at the border between mexico
and us
and ah thank you
kikito the little kid is one year old
and he lives in a little house you see
on the top left of the image i just
wonder at his age what is his
perspective on the world
you know each time i do a project i
wonder
cannot change the world
and i never really know how a project
starts
a couple years ago i was making
breakfast
and a friend of mine called me friend
saul he said jaya you love walls
why don't you do a project in prison i
was like ah you know i was just dude i
you know i would do it but it's too much
paperwork administrative bureaucracy
plus i've been arrested 15 times they
don't want me in there
and he was like i know bro but you love
all so much what you would do in there
what you know what if you could do it
what you could do i was like okay you
know what
i had an idea if i wanted to finish my
push tags and my
you know french toast before it gets
cold i had to get rid of him so i told
him you know what i'll paste the entire
prison he was like wow that's amazing he
hung up the phone i he i thought i'd
never hear from him for two decades he
called his friend scott scott was like
what's up soul he's like i spoke to jr
he's down to do a project in prison it's
got like wow that's amazing let me call
the governor hang up the phone call the
governor governor was like wait i'm
sorry what is this who's this jr see
he's do black and white and you know he
takes
photos of people he records their story
and it
i'm sorry i've never heard of it yes
there's very large murals and the
governor was like wait wait wait
before i was a governor
i was in a mural
there was 1300 people each one of them
recorded a story and i was one of them
is that the same artist
the guy said yes that's the semester
give him full clearance for every
present in the state of california
calls me back next thing you know i'm on
google earth and there's 35 prisons so
i'm looking at them and i'm like well
first of all i'm a wallpaper man i
cannot paste if i don't have my clear
surface so that doesn't work that
doesn't work that doesn't work this is
the yard is made of sand and grass i
cannot do it i know nothing about
prisons so then i see this one and i'm
like wait can we zoom in this one i'm
like oh actually you know what the yard
here in the center looks like it's
concrete i could walk on that
like look gel that's that's a super max
security prison
it's called tehachapi it's actually in
the top five of the most violent prison
i was like that will do it the next day
we flew there
we arrived there
and of course you know it's not that
easy you get there it's like fences
electric fences walls and you add more
walls and more people that check your
ids and
my god i get all the way to the yard
and it looks like some army guy with
like bulletproof jackets and heavily
armed who say all right this is going to
be very simple there's some people
waiting for you in the gymnasium we
gather some inmates you cannot approach
them you cannot touch them you can sit
at the chair that we designated for you
and we're gonna surround the area of the
gymnasium
that sounds fun
i enter the room and we do this thing in
france i don't know if you have that but
you shake people's hand you know so i
started shaking people's hand hello how
are you my name is jr what's your name
and go around the table and then i sat
and
i spoke with them
a lot of them have been there since they
were teenagers some of them even from
the age of 13
and i've never seen anything like it and
so
i told them about my art and about the
idea and they asked me a question they
said but
what is the purpose of your art
i was like well you know that's a good
question i i don't know if i can answer
before you know trying a project so i
explained them an idea
and i said wait before we start anything
i just want you to know
if there's anyone here in this room
that by being in this project you might
often some of your victims outside i'm
not your guy i'm going to get too much
attention for you
if i were you
don't participate to this project
six or seven guys stood up and left the
room i was like all right so we kept on
going and i started photographing them
very simple it's just a small part of
the process i'm not really a
photographer that's just one part that i
use and i get to meet them and talk with
them and each of them started explaining
me their story where they grew up
where they come from how many years some
of them spent decades in this prison
and the thing is that i told them i said
look you know this photo is nothing i
need you to
go in the next room i'm gonna leave a
mic there
and i want you to record your story
from the beginning i want to understand
you have to talk like if you're throwing
a bottle in the ocean i want to
understand where you come from
and then what brought you to make that
that crime that lead you to prison
and if you change explain how you change
and why
they all went some stay for 10 minutes
some say for 20 30 minutes
some of them were crying in this in that
place
then i went back to my studio and that's
what we do we print strips of paper like
a giant puzzle so we have to combine it
together it's all just paper and glue
and then we combine them by numbers and
then we went back there and we started
bringing everybody on the yard
and we started pasting everyone from
every gang every race participated
now the thing is
we're still in a supermax security
prison so the guys were like look
we love you with your like paper and
stuff and but we're gonna count
everything you brought in and we're
gonna make sure you live with everything
out so every hour we're gonna stop this
whole project and make sure there's not
one scissors missing one brush one you
know bucket anything
so we went to the process and i had
planned two to three days to place the
whole thing
those guys were so motivated
that in literally two or three hours we
had done it so i said wait stop guys
they're gonna bring you back to your
cell give me a second i'm gonna try to
get some guards to pace with us and
they're like look you know we love your
eutopism and stuff but like that's where
it stopped like no no just give me a
second so i start going to the gods and
i say hey do you mean participating no
no no 50 no one guy said yes say cool
come with me they're going to show you
and then another guard and another guy
and that's where the real walls were
falling down because there's no
communication between those guards and
the inmates
and you know what
from the floor it was so big we couldn't
see it anyway you had to send a drone so
remember again you're in a supermax
security prison it's geo-fencing
so we're sending the drone those guys
have never seen a drone their whole life
they were more excited about the drone
than the whole project
and i was so scared because i was like i
hope we did the puzzle right because if
not it's gonna look a bit ugly from up
there
and that's what you see from up there
that's what you see from up there
thank you the whole yard all their faces
and when you zoom in actually
you see the picnic table you can still
see it looks like a hole but it's
actually an illusion
and you see the guys working on it
now
the craziest part of all of it is
because of that crazy permit that i had
i literally walked in without being
searched i had my phone on me so i
started filming in there
and posting it on social media
so this guy there was showing me his
tattoo on day one
and then the evening he called his
family and they said we saw you on
jail's instagram it's incredible we see
what you guys are doing he was so proud
the next day he said yeah do you mind me
showing my diplomas
they started realizing the impact of
suddenly having a connection with the
outside
then these guys show up his name is
kevin
when he you know i when i saw him i was
like well in my life i never have a
second chance to ask a guy hopefully
why he have a [ __ ] swastika on his
face
and so i asked him i said and he was
like oh this almost like he forgot about
it he's like i did this as a gang thing
when i went in prison
but now if i could i would remove it
i was like okay do you mind if i take a
photo and i share it he's like yeah sure
i share that photo now as you can
imagine on social media a lot of people
was as shocked and offended as i was
but a lot of people were like that's
strange because that doesn't connect
with the beauty in his eyes and the
humanity in him
so i went back to him and i said look
kevin there's this thing called social
media i know you've been here too long
you don't know about this but people
writing comments i'm going to write read
them to you and i think some of them you
should answer
so we started talking and i did many and
many videos
and asking him again and again and he
responded and he went deeper and deeper
and it started a chain of people who
were like let's get this tattoo out of
his face
okay so now before we reveal the image
that you saw i didn't want to throw it
to the world like that for now only the
inmates and i have seen it
we started an app where you can actually
go in it's totally free and you can go
and click on any faces and hear the
story for as much as they want
i wonder you know i've seen it i've saw
people telling me that they heard story
and like a podcast and but i wonder how
would they feel about how you know i
wanted the feedback from them
so i got a permit to go back in the
prison and this time i say let me walk
on some more walls i'll find an idea let
me get back in so i go back in there
and i started walking on the walls but
it was really the excuse was like i need
to speak to you guys so i said what
happened guys they were like well what
do you mean what happened i was like
well i was in the outside i can't speak
to you guys
what was the impact inside it's like oh
the impact inside is pretty simple
let me tell you for myself i mean my
daughter never visited me in 14 years
and now she sat in her bedroom and she
listened to my audio and now she sees me
every week
he says you can ask to every one of
those guys here
and they'll tell you the same story
and he told me another thing happened is
that the guards started listening to our
stories they treat us differently now
then we started seeing the walls falling
down so i left a little souvenir in the
courtyard i was like alright let me make
one more wall disappear before i go so
we pasted the mountains from behind the
wall on the wall and it's still there
actually
this one is still in level four which is
the supermax security prison and they
told me in winter it becomes all snowy
and so you actually don't tell the
difference between the reality and the
wall
now kevin was still in prison so i
visited him again and
something had changed in him
he was already helping others and
you know you could tell he he almost had
forgotten about his tattoo even if it
was still there because you cannot
remove tattoos in prison
so i brought him a book
and i told him look there's a swastika
on the cover i thought you'd like it and
he laughed but i said no seriously this
is our friend art spiegelman who wrote
it
and he told the story about his family
in the holocaust
and so that night
he went and read the book
and he was really moved he called his
mom and he said mom you know those
french people they brought me this book
talks about the holocaust and
she said but you stupid [ __ ]
your family was from poland they were
hiding jews there at the time they died
in austria because of protecting them
and you go in prison and do this on your
face
he was in shock
a couple years later which is a couple
months ago
he came out
like many others from the project
almost all of them got moved to a lower
security prison
and one third of them got freed because
of having good grades and notes by the
guards after all the project
so kevin went out and the first thing he
did
was to go up that hill that he looked at
for 17 years
to look down at the prison that he was
staying in
and then the second thing as i promised
him
i took him to
a doctor to remove his tattoo
and the session started with the lazar
and it's it's very painful
and at the end of it
the doctor removed
the lazar and she told him well who's
better than a jewish doctor to remove
your swastika
and that's him now
yeah
you know we really try to bring that we
really try to bring him here but his
spiral officer who is actually really
nice he said yeah you're pushing too
much he's not going to canada
sorry about this
but he knows i'm here talking about it
you know i'm i want to use out as a
bridge to make people talk to each other
i'm not an activist i'm just an artist i
don't try to tell people what to think i
just try to make them think
and i really see how
to me it's like it's in the process
that's what's important and after this
whole project after everything i showed
you
what shook them what struck them the
most
is that i shook their hand so at the end
they even asked me for a hug
now
i remember their first question which
was what is the purpose of your art
well art can change things
but can it change the world or can you
change a man
before you answer that question think
at some point of in your life have you
changed
and if yes
if you did why can't they
thank you
thank you
thank you
that's amazing you're amazing um
you also just got back from the ukraine
and i wanted to show us just another
piece of your work
oh yeah that was in ukraine
and the biggest city in the west side of
ukraine is called el vive
and
i i
had a friend of mine took that photo at
the border he sent it to me i printed it
150 feet long we rolled it as a top walk
through the border with it
it's actually easy to go that way you
know to enter ukraine so nobody like was
like are you gonna go this way sure and
then we drove to you know i met some
people on instagram and they came and
picked me up in the car
and then we gathered hundreds of people
we wanted to show putin's planes who
they were shooting out
and so
that little girl
is actually safe
when she got photographed she was coming
out of the country so she's not in in
vassovia and and she's she's okay and
since then actually
we're moving this image all around
europe so while ted was happening in the
last four days the image was in berlin
dusseldorf venice this morning
and then it will keep traveling and each
time its place people are gathering by
themselves and opening it up that is
amazing jr thank you thank you